wir haben vor zwei Stunden endlich
unsere App released an der wir 10 Monate
gearbeitet haben und es gab direkt ein
Problem und zwar sind für die letzte
Stunde keine Registrierungsmail bei
vielen Leuten angekommen dafür haben wir
jetzt eine Lösung ihr könnt euch
registrieren und wenn ihr euch schon
registriert habt einfach direkt mit den
Registrierungsdaten anmelden ihr bekommt
als bald so schnell es geht morgen
wahrscheinlich eine Bestätigungsmail für
das Registrieren des Accounts und hab
dann 7 Tage Zeit den Account zu
registrieren also es funktioniert wieder
alle rein da vielen Dank für euren
Support unglaublich das wird so guter
Vorbereitung tatsächlich eingeklappt
sind